salut aujourd'hui je vous donne d'abord
la réponse de l'énigme d'hier si vous
l'avez pas regarder aller la voir aller
hyper intéressante en fonction de cette
réponse là mais comme la réponse la
donne maintenant si vous n'avez pas vu
l'énigme aller la voir de suite pour
résoudre cette énigme
il faut créer un paradoxe un paradoxe
c'est par exemple si je vous dis cette
phrase est fausse c'est un paradoxe
parce que si ma phrase il faut se dire
qu'elle est vraie mais si elle est vraie
c'est à dire qu'elle est fausse mais si
à défaut ça veut dire qu'elle est vraie
et donc il n'y a jamais de solution
c'est un paradoxe au complet et b c'est
exactement ce qu'on va faire devant le
génie la question vous allez lui poser
c'est est ce que la prochaine réponse
que vous allez me donner et non il peut
pas répondre à ça parce que s'il dit oui
alors il a menti les souvenez-vous le
génie peut pas mentir
mais s'il dit non alors ça marche pas il
a menti aussi parce qu'il vient de dire
non donc il aurait dû dire oui et là
vous avez écrit un paradoxe donc il ne
peut pas répondre à la question donc
vous pouvez passer
j'avoue j'ai été un peu galère celle là
mais je la trouvais hyper intéressante
dans son explication est l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui sera moins compliqué et
c'est maintenant et nîmes eu deux plages
pour l'énigme 5
non j'ai pas chanter n'importe quoi et
énigmes 5 à touristes va à la plage sur
son trajet il croise deux femmes ayant
chacune deux enfants un couple avec un
chien trois adolescents qui sont
ensemble est l'un des enfants à un
landau avec un petit poupon un bébé ma
question est combien de personnes vont à
la plage chercher et s'est trouvée
attention comme dans toutes les énigmes
la première réponse qui vous viendra ne
sera peut-être pas la bonne vous pouvez
en parler dans les commentaires mais ne
mettez pas la réponse laisser les autres
chercher par contre dès que vous avez
trouvé mettez un pouce en l'air pour
qu'on voit le nombre de personnes qui
ont trouvé la solution on le sait
maintenant ce que je veux pour vous il
faut que vous profitiez du soleil que
vous passiez un bel été que vous vous
abonniez à la chaîne et rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao